雨やばこんばんは初め社長です
1週間日替わり心霊スポットに通ったら
どうなるの
はい1日目です皆さんは心霊スポットと
いう場所に行ったことがありますでしょう
か僕ですね結構動画で心霊スポットに行く
ことが多々あるんですけれども
やっぱ怖いんですよ当たり前ですけど
慣れるとかないんですもう心のその
恐怖って決まっても絶対消えなくて
霊感があるわけじゃないのでそういう何か
を感じるとかないんですけども基本的に
もう
怖くて怖くて仕方がないけど動画は撮り
たいそんなカットに日々悩んでる心霊
スポット行きたい系YouTuberなん
ですけれども
雨やばいな今日すごい雨降ってますそこで
私思いましたこの恐怖心を克服するために
は心霊スポットに通い続けるしかないと
それも毎回同じ心霊スポットに行くと
恐怖心への慣れじゃなくて場所に対する
慣れになると思うので私初めてですよ今日
から1週間毎日日替わりで違う心霊
スポットに通い続けます
日替わりで変わる心霊スポット毎回違う
恐怖が待っています果たして1週間通い
続けると僕はどうなってしまうのか心霊
スポットになれるのかまた精神崩壊を
起こしてしまうのかちょっと検証として
やってみたいと思います1日目の心霊
スポットは静岡県でも上位に君臨します旧
本社がトンネル静岡県と愛知県の間にある
トンネルに来ておりますであの一人で来
てるわけではなく一応何かあった時に注意
も後輩連れてきておりますちょっと運転と
か頼んだみたいなお前も苦手そうだな
待ち時間もしんどいです
何かあった時に一応連れてきてはいるので
そこはちょっと大丈夫だと思いますただ
心霊スポットに行くのは僕一人で行きます
ので
ちょっと行ってくるわ行ってきます
いや雨降ってるからさ逆になんか物音は気
にならないよねうん確かに
行かなくなったんだけどさっきついてたよ
あーやばいまじこれ
着きました
いやー
寒気がすごい
普通にやばいよ
やばい
[音楽]
[拍手]
精神崩壊しちゃうマジで
やばい
普通にやばいちょっと待って結構無理かも
あーやばいどうしようどうしようどう
しようどうしようどうしようどうしよう
どうしようどうしようどうしよう
奥まで行くしかないよなでもこれ
行くか
ちょっと
初日やばいですねどうしよう結構無理かも
もう
えっライト消えてんだけど
無理無理ついたついた
結構無理
[音楽]
やばい何も考えられないどうしよう
普通に頭おかしくなりそうです
背中がやばい
背中のやばい恐怖が
もう
この先真っ暗です何もないやばい
いやーちょっと待って本当にあのねいつも
心霊スポット来る時誰かと来るんですよ
絶対そういう時はいけるんですけど本当に
一人きりで死ぬスポット来る時はもうね
あーやばいちょっと待って
[音楽]
やばい
俺の視点見る俺の視点これだよ今
あれなんか
人影見える気のせいですか
やばいアンパンマンかな
無理本当に無理やばい
[音楽]
え消えたんだけど
治って
治って本当に無理本当に治ってなんでなん
でなんでなんでなんでなんでそんな壊れる
のこれ意味わかんないんだけど
え誰誰
もうほんとやだ次消えたら帰ります
[音楽]
あもうすぐでもゴールですやばいライト
消える意味がわからんライト消える意味が
わからんライト消える意味がわからんけど
[笑い]
愛知県ですねもうもう
[拍手]
怖い怖い怖い無理無理無理だから
怖いよ
ライト4回ぐらい入れた
まじ
やばいやばい
1日目行ってきました
[音楽]
最近買いました行く前にほら帰ってきたら
普通につくんですけど何にもつかなくて
トンネルの中がすごい落書きだらけで結構
パニックチックになりましたね
一人で行くことあんまないんですよ
カメラマンとかさいつもこういう時ついて
くるじゃん
心霊スポットの奥まで行くとかっていうの
は結構
精神的にきつくてちゃんとやっぱ苦手だ
なっていうのを再認識した紹介でした
もっといい日になるといいねハチ太郎
2日目です
やばいわ目の前にしたら普通に怖い
慣れとかやっぱそんなすぐ来るもんじゃ
ないんですねというわけで2日目はですね
二の岡神社という神社に来ております心霊
と出てきますね知ってた知りません知ら
ない
[音楽]
あーもうちょっと本当にやばくない神社も
また雰囲気違いますね
良かった車で僕
誰かいないちょっと待って本当やめて
くださいまじまじまじ
嘘
鳥居周辺に怪奇現象が多いらしいので
すぐそこにあるやつね
鳥居周辺見てみようかなと思います外国人
の幽霊が出るという
噂があるらしいですじゃあ行ってきます5
分をやばいわ普通に2日目でも結構もう
嫌だなって思う気持ちが強いですねこれ
いつ慣れるんだろうな
待ってでも怖い行ってきますいっ
てらっしゃい
[音楽]
結構マジで無理かも今日なんか今日2つ
めっちゃ暑かったのに
寒いですよこれですね
俺マジでこれ行くのか
[音楽]
バチバチ言ってない
いきます
ほらなんか音が
行きます
待って
やばい
[音楽]
昨日よりやばいぞこれこれ潜っていいのか
な本当に
失礼します
怖いです
鳥居をくぐってしまいました
うまいね
これどこに繋がってるん
だやばいずっと奥まであるんだこれ
絶対一人で来れないよなんか広いしどこが
ゴールなんだろうでも鳥居が一番やばいっ
てことはもういいよね普通に帰っても俺
そんなに
得意じゃないですよ
死んでこの先であってんだろうなぁ
そうですよね
[音楽]
登っちゃいますよ
ね行けちゃうんですねこれが
寒気が止まらないどこまで続くの待って
帰り道のことを考えるともう僕無理ですよ
もう真っ暗だ
どこまで行けばいいんだゴールは存在する
のか
信者にしたら長くないか
中身の階段
返すことができないような今日を感じます
え待って長くないこの先どこまで僕は行け
ばいいの
やばいすげー体調悪い
これごめんなさいそろそろいいでしょうか
色々見ましたよね
まずいなんかすごい嫌だ
やばいなんか体がダメって言ってる気が
する
熱帯地域の生き物がおるな背中がやばい
絶対
振り返っちゃダメな感じがあります
つい
すいません入りますごめんなさいもう無理
今日はこの辺にしましょう
おかえりなさい
どうでしょう
何も変わらんもう何にも変わらずも
ひたすらに怖いですねメンタルが心配自分
の
明日に期待します
深めです
なんかね2日目から頭痛が止まらなくて
ですね何なんだろう
精神的に結構苦しんでるのかなという感じ
ありますけども新しいシーンでスポットに
行きました今日来たのですね昔も行った
ことがあるんですけれども人はなっていう
静岡県にある結構有名な心霊スポットに
なります
ネットで見ても激震でスポットって書いて
あるね神社の裏手には溶岩で固まってきた
竪穴の洞窟があるとまあそれが人はなって
言われてるとこですね人の形の人魂が出る
とか人穴の中はレイだらけ今回の目標は
その人はななんか心霊スポットというか
パワースポットとも言われてますねパワー
もらえればいいけどね頭痛が気になる部分
はありますけれども今日も元気に行って
いきたいと思いますなんかどんどん言って
ない金曜日の夜なのねだから多分俺以外に
も示そうと行く人がいるっぽいんですよね
ありがとう一人で行くより全然助かるけど
ね行くのは本当に一人で行くのでじゃあ
早速行ってきます
ね
[音楽]
かなり大きい人がいる人がいるこのまま
[拍手]
返してくれなかった私で人だったのだろう
かいやいやなんか風がないのにさ1個だけ
揺れてんの何なんで左から2番目だけ
あんな揺れてんの
すごい揺れてない1個だけ普通4つとも
言えないおかしいってそのやり方は
とりもくぐったということで行きましょう
か
まぁすごいありがたいことにですね
街灯ついてるんですね
ちょろいね1日目2日目の場所には該当
なんてなかった今回こんなんもうライト
いいんですかありがとうって感じで俺行き
ますけどね
やっぱ何か感じるなこういう椅子とか
ちょっと怖いですね
ここかな
この中ですね多分入っちゃダメって書いて
ある
深い穴がある
すごいな
久々に来たなこういう感じの場所ですね
なんか中からコツコツ聞こえるんだけど
なんかやばいな人だってこれのことだよね
どういう声
なんか今女の人の笑い声でもないし叫び声
でも何とも言えない声があったぞ人はこれ
でいいのかな
もうちょっと奥行ってみますか
何もないこの先は
真っ暗
無事にとりあえず人は何をつけたので
クリアではないでしょうか中に入ることは
ダメなので中はこんな風になってるんだ
帰りますねはいお疲れ様でした
幽霊の皆さんも連れ出したキャスティング
お疲れ様でしたスタッフの皆さんキャスト
の皆さんお疲れ様でした僕帰ります帰る道
を選ばせていただきます全然帰らせて
ください
いやずっと気になってるのが1つあって
なんでその揺れてるんだろういやこれは
もうちょっとわかんないですね皆さん
帰り道あるんですけども全然1日目2日目
に比べるとなんか
怖さが薄れました心霊スポットが原因なの
かもしれないし俺が耐性がついたのかも
わかんないんですけど今日はそんなに
大丈夫ですこれ乗り切ったかこれで明日も
怖くなかったら結構
克服した説あるけど
今日はこんな感じでした帰ります
[音楽]
4日目ですはいちょっと今日は健介が運転
手としてきておりますあのね昨日は余裕
だったのよ実はなんと心霊スポット内に
街灯がありまして
笑顔でフィニッシュ
パワースポットぐらい力もあったぐらい
だったのでだいぶなんかメンタルは安定し
ているんですけどもこれが果たしてあの
場所の効果なのかそれでも通ったことに
よる慣れなのかまだわからないので
ちょっと4日目行ってみたいと思います
今日行くところですね明治トンネルと言わ
れている動画でも何回か切ったことがある
心霊スポットの有名なトンネルですね通称
おばけトンネルと言われております
人影が現れては消える人の気配がするなど
噂がありますので早速1人で行ってきたい
と思います
行ってきます
今日は雨が降ってますね
行ってきます隣に車がいるのがちょっと
怖いですね
だめだ
今日も怖い
昨日は街灯あったからだったんだやばい
マジで来い
ここかいや俺
企画でも何回か来たことあるから
慣れてるはずなんですけど
めっちゃ木折れてるな
慣れないなぁ
慣れないですこればかりは
風強い意識を
何かを感じたけどこれですね人いないよね
やめてね本当に見えるかな
これがお化けトンネル明治トンネルです
奥は光があるのね
今回はとりあえず
奥まで行けばクリアって感じじゃない
でしょうかただ落書き少ないな
民度がいいのか
山奥すぎて誰も来ないのかなどっちかです
ねただきついです
風強いトンネルで天井怖いよね毎回思うん
だけど逆に天井以外怖くないまである今回
も多くにライトがあるからなそれで
ちょっと怖くない説までありますね
怖いわやっぱり怖いわ結局今日も怖かった
ちゃんと
足音した今
あーなんかちょっとやだ
なここから照明がありますねサムネ用です
さあもうすぐゴールです皆さんはいもう来
ました来ました
逆側まで来ましたはい
ちょっと怖いですねちょっと
怖いです
なんか怖さというより気配は感じません
何かのその恐怖はあるけどなんかそんな
初日みたいにパニックになるとかないです
ね4日目か
静かだなこのトンネル
音聞こえたら結構無理だよ
いや暗いとやっぱ怖いな
怖い怖いです
でも怖いけど
行けますやっぱ照明があるかないかって
結構変わりそうだな
ゴールゴールやっぱ
慣れとかってあるのかな俺今日行けてます
もんこれ
帰ってきました
余裕でした
もちろん怖いんですよその気配を感じ立て
たとかそういう愛のあったんですけども
そういうなんか一人だからやばいみたいな
パニック状態はもう
克服したんじゃないかというかまったく
なかったです
けど本当に危ないやばいみたいな状態は
ないんじゃないかなすごい3日目4日目
これで出るからちょっと次もちょっと
楽しみですね
楽しみもどうなっちゃうのか自分が
お祓いの準備だけお願いします
どうも5日目ですはい
ちょっとね来てますマジでいける今日来た
のはですねさっき看板にもあったと思うん
ですけれども
旅籠池という池ですね今日は池に来ており
ます昔ですねここら辺には機織り服のやつ
ね機織りがたくさんいたらしくてその
機織りの前にこの池で身を清めていたと
いう言っがありまして機織りを命じられた
期日とかがあったらしくてそれまでに感染
できなかったらしくて自殺とかがあった
らしいですなんかその機織りの音みたいな
聞こえたりするというのが噂ではあります
今の俺なら多分いけると思いますだんだん
この軽くなってくるのも自分が怖いんです
行ってきます
[拍手]
いきなりそういう感じか何なんだろうこれ
なんか小さめのやつ3つありますね
あと今日すごいのがね
霧が
めっちゃ濃いのよ超綺麗がかかってる
大丈夫
ちょっと
怖すぎて普通にちょっと開けといてもいい
ですかダメです
帰ってくるからね
早いな待って次が濃すぎてやばいぞ奥が
何にも見えないキレが濃くて
[音楽]
いや怖いなこの切りパターン珍しいですね
今でその霧がめっちゃ濃いとかなかった
からなどこに池があるんだそして
パキって言った
つきました
旅行け公園なんですねまっすぐ行けばある
んだね
行きましょうか
めちゃめちゃ広い
何にも見えない
ここが池になってるんだあポジション
ポチョンって言ったけど
閉鎖的な心霊スポットじゃなくてこういう
ね開けたシーンでスポットも結構怖いです
ね
もうなんか
異世界に来てる気分だもんちょっと池の
近く行ってみますか
池の中に入っちゃダメなのね
わかりました
なんかいる
[音楽]
います
なんかブクブク聞こえるんだけど
お魚さんかな
なるほどね
[音楽]
うん
怖いねちょっと
怖いわ
なんか感じるめっちゃ
蜘蛛の巣やっぱ心霊スポットの
難易度的に
街灯があるかないかめっちゃ重要だと思う
のよナイト急にこんな怖いから
[音楽]
ぶくぶくって言ってるはいちょっと池の
周りはこんな感じでした開けてる分恐怖感
はそんなにないですねよしOK行き止まり
も確認できたんで帰ります
マジで魚怖い
わ
池とか怖いよねなんか足とか引きずられ
そうでそこ行きの時バキッと落とした
なんかいるかな
自分から音する方に行けるようになっ
ちゃってる
[音楽]
もん大丈夫だよね
なんせ
霧が濃くてやばい
[音楽]
お疲れ様でした
いやーまあまあ怖いね霧のせいで世界
観というか
入ってきた食べて無理だってもうマジで
とりあえず
行ったいやわかんないですちょっとねその
水辺っていうのもね結構例が集まると言わ
れてるので結構
乗り切れましたなんかパキッと音がした
場所があって自分からそこ行ったよ
頑張ります
どうも
というわけで6日目でございます一番怖い
あと2日しかないですから上げていこうね
もうね怖いものないような気がしてます
正直ただやっぱ服とちょっとヒヤッとする
のと俺この企画始めてからずっと訳じゃ
ないんですけども新スポーツ家族旅に頭痛
がするようになりました
受賞
今日そして明日明後日にはお祓いに行き
たいので予約お願いしますはい行き
ましょうすぐ行きましょうかなりねこん
だけ毎日行ってるとさすがにどうかしそう
なんですけれどもやっぱ慣れが来てる気は
してます
こんばんは
動画
撮影をしてます
はい
僕あのはじめしゃちょーと言います
あそうです
駒場すいませんいやもうすぐ
ニュース
そうです
ただもうすぐ帰るのではい
すいません全然怪しいものじゃないですお
願いしますありがとうございますご苦労様
です
名前言うと手っ取り早く大事です今日行く
ところがですね
静岡県の
千本浜という場所にある
首塚という場所があります今までの場所と
ちょっと違ってこう道道
沿いになるんですけれども
歴史としてちゃんとこういうことがあり
ましたというのがちゃんとあって明治33
年1900年ですねなんかここら辺の地域
で頭蓋骨が発見されたっていうニュースが
ありますおそらくだけど戦国時代の合戦と
かでの戦死者の所有のじゃないかと言われ
ていますまあ本当に首のない若い武者が
現れるだったり火の玉が出るとか
千本浜っていうぐらいで浜だから海がある
らしくて泳ぐとなんか連れてかれるとか
そういう噂もあるらしいです100体以上
の首とかそういう噂もマジで怖すぎる首塚
って言うとやっぱ怖いイメージあります
からねじゃあ早速首塚一人で行っていき
たいと思います
一番怖い本当に行ってきますやっぱ海の
近くですね波の音が聞こえますしでもなん
か
寒気がしますねどこだろう首塚なんか
まっすぐ行ったら車も通るんだこんな
人通りが多い場所で本当に心霊スポットが
あるのでしょうかあとゴミポイ捨てすな
わああああ
ゴミが踏まれたさあどこら辺に首塚はある
のでしょうか今のところどこに大丈夫よ
沼津西高校の皆さんこんにちは僕です
いやー多分俺これやっぱ慣れてるのかな
慣れてますは多分全然怖くないですどこに
あるかだけちょっと気になりますね
あった多分これだうーんこれですね
首塚
波の音が怖いこれが首塚ですねいや本当に
普通にこういう路地というか道の間にあり
ますね
ここが正面ですね
でも寒い
寒いな海沿いだから風が強いんでしょうか
ちょっとここら辺普通にお家とかもあるの
で早めに帰らせていただきます
失礼します海の付近ということでなんか
その波の音だったり風の音夜風がすごい
不気味な雰囲気を漂わせていますがこんな
怖くないですね俺やっぱ慣れちゃったのか
なこれ
心霊スポット
ここそんな可能性ありますよこれサクッと
戻りますただいまです
いかがでした
[音楽]
もちろんなんかその
怖かったけど
余裕これねワン克服してます多分マジか
わかんない今回もちょっと該当ある場所
だったのでそこら辺の安心感みたいな部分
はあったんですけどももちろんその海沿い
独特の
生ぬるい風でちょっと
怖い感じ心霊スポットになるだろうなって
いう気持ちは分かりますけども何度か堪え
ましたはいもうこの調整7日目バーン行っ
てもう終わらせましょう
告白しました
はいというわけで7日目最終日です1日目
から始めて1週間心霊スポット通って今日
が最終日まあさすがに最後ぐらいはねもう
生き返りの運転から心霊スポットまで
完全に一人っきりでやっていきたいと思い
ますあのでも耐性は多分ついたと思うん
ですよかなりもう怖い雰囲気の心霊
スポットも一人で行きますし
街灯がない心霊スポットも一人で行けます
変な物音としてもまあある程度なら
耐えれると思います今回の企画で耐性が
ついたと思うので最後は一人で全国心霊
スポットランキング第3位のところに来
ました
旧前場トンネルでございます
[音楽]
最後にふさわしいな神奈川県にある
トンネルで
過去に1回だけね後輩と一緒に来たことが
あるんですけれどもかなり久々ですね
神奈川県の超有名なトンネルとなっており
ますもう1回どんな噂があるか確認しよう
か
事故でなくなった人なんかすごい人の
視線を感じるんですが
無視していきましょうバイクと対向車の
トラックが正面衝突事故で人が亡くなって
いますねまあ飾る心霊スポットの中で全国
第3位と言われている正真正銘のやばい
場所に今から最終日1人で行っていきたい
と思いますこの心霊スポット巡りも最後と
なるとちょっとだけ
寂しい気もしますねさあ行きましょうか
なんかもうパチパチ言ってない
となんか
やばいなぁ
北が違うずっと顔ぼやけてるしどういう
ことなの
よかった
なんでそんなピント合わないの
めっちゃ悪いんだけど
[音楽]
トンネルまで道が結構長いんですよ
風邪ないのにめっちゃバキバキ言ってんだ
けど
やめて全く勝てないのに全方向から
バキバキ言ってる
そういう仕様いややばいやばいですマジで
無理
やばい
何今の音なんか生き物の音が超でかくなっ
てきてる
行きましょう行きましょう行きましょう
もうすぐ9000番トンネルです
何
誰もいないのにも聞かない音しなかった
ほらなんか
俺の全方向からバキバキ聞こえるんです
けど
なにこれついちゃったついちゃった
できました
9前場トンネル日本第3位のトンネルです
落ちてきてる
なんか降ってきてない
やばい
結構きついかもトンネル着きました
[音楽]
ここです
あ
っと響く系か
[音楽]
なんか
本当にやばい心霊スポットって街灯とか
関係ないねバッチバチに
怖い
耳が
耳聞こえなくなった左なんてなんでなんで
なんで
すいませんネタじゃない方でちょっと
まずいかもしれんとりあえず向こうまで
行って帰ってきたら
終わり
で左耳が過度なストレスによるなんか
耳の突発性の何かかいやこんなにライト
明るいのにさ
めちゃくちゃ怖いのよ
やばいです
怖すぎです
これが
さっきなってたのこの空き缶かなでも人の
気配はないですね
無事に最後まで来れました
次は割となんかホテル街というか堺でそう
ですねじゃあ戻ります
雰囲気えぐすぎ
[音楽]
帰るぞ
やばい怖い怖い
こんなピチピチ言ってたっけさっき
今なんかこれミキミキミキってなかった
あーなんかもうごめんなさいあんまり気に
しないで行きます
持たないなこれ俺が
いやマジでバットだよ
もうすぐ出口
まで
いやこれトンネル前がやばいな多分ありえ
ないレベルの音してるんですけど車に戻る
までがこの企画だ
気を抜かずに帰ります
おかしいでしょだってこんなことなるの
ちょっと意味がわからなすぎる
まあ大丈夫ですけど
大丈夫じゃないなぁ
無意識に何かを感じちゃうなここいやまだ
怖いまだ怖い
やばい声出ちゃっ
た
ちょっとだけ慣れた
[音楽]